it not supposed to be here
50an
us got to pick sides man one of the
armies pick the bigger Army
good sunny and warm
I was in 70 degree weather walking by
the beach 24 hours
ago okay folks um
I'm so unused to Tuesday classes that I
actually did not set up a zoom session
for today which is kind of irrelevant
because you're already here so I know a
few people who've been sitting on Zoom
every session and they're wondering
where the link
is today they'll have to catch up with
the recording because I did set it up
right now so it shows up um couple of
things by now I will not even ask you
the question I will assume from this day
on that you have a company and you have
a group but there were a couple of
people who did email me last week from
this class saying they didn't have a
group yet could you please put up your
hand don't feel any Shame about this
this is not something to be ashamed
about this will allow other groups to
say I want an extra person so if you're
not in a group could you put your hand
up
okay um Can there are a couple of people
here is there there any groups that can
add a person I would consider it a
personal favor if you can add an extra
person on and if you already have seven
I will like the Pope give you special
dispensation to add an extra person and
go to eight or even nine so by the end
of today I hope to get you adopted so
don't worry about it put it out of your
mind and while you don't have a group
you can still pick a company so find a
group pick a company and get
started so today we're actually going to
leave discount rates behind us we're
very close to the end and talk about
earnings and cash flows so I want to ask
a few questions about earnings and cash
flows first what dat are you valuing
your companies as
of you remember what's the last day of
class May 5th right your valuation is of
May
5th the reason I bring that up is what's
the last financial statement that most
of you will have
as of May 5th
Sophia if you're lucky that's going to
be really close right first quarter will
end on March 31st maybe your company
will come out before because some of you
will be in fact if I ask you to value
your company
today what's the last 10K you're going
to have for most of you for some many of
you it's still 2023 you don't have 2024
yet you see where I'm going right that
information you have is not always
updated constantly some of it is what
parts of your valuation are going to get
updated every moment of every
day what goes into discount rate what's
your starting point tondre right I just
checked it before I left for class by
the time I get back it's going to be a
different number it's going to be update
your Equity risk premium I'll update for
you you don't have to do it at the start
of every month so you can get at the
start of May if you want to right risk
free rates and Equity risk beams are
going to be in con will your market
price get updated every moment of every
day yeah your market price will be as of
May 5 don't let consistency become the
enemy of delivering an updated valuation
in other words don't hear me tell me
that your last financial report came out
in December 31st your valuations of
January 1st first I don't care what your
valuation is of January 1st what are we
going to do with it anyway you can't act
on it second it's not technically true
that your last financial statement came
out in December 31st right
it probably came out in March or April
so by the time you actually get
disclosure it's going to be later this
is going to be a constant issue when you
valuation some information is updated
some is lagging and accounting
information in particular will always
have a lag because accountants don't
update numbers every every day maybe not
even every month once every three months
but the rule in evaluation is you want
the most updated data you can find for
every piece of information
so let's suppose you want to get the
most updated earnings number for your
company let's do it as of today because
right now it's still a challenge for
many of you your last 10K might be the
2023 number so that's one choice go back
and look at the last 10K in your
response is what are the choice do I
have that's my last financial statement
the second thing you could do is take
the last quarterly earnings you got
which might have been through what
September of
2024 and multiply by four
quarter Time 4 is a year let that kind
of simar in your mindset is that going
to make sense you could add together the
earnings of the last four
quarters what's that called does anybody
know what that is that's called trailing
12 month data or last 12 months TTM LTM
I mean I don't particularly like to use
the abbreviation because often have no
idea what but it's the last 12 months so
basically or you can take the earnings
for the year to date which might be for
the first 9 months of 2024 and they're
often forecasts for the fourth quarter
that you can use to fill in first let's
rule out the number you the two that you
should never be using
sopia and what's the
problem okay so problem with B is you
take the last quarter you multiply by
four you're going to get all kinds of
seasonality you take a retail firm you
take the last quarters earnings and
multiply by four it's going to look
really good because they get 40 50% of
the revenues in the last quarter you
can't do that so rule that up the last
10K what's the problem with it it's
old he's saying how much can happen in a
year and a half come
on how much has happened in the last
year and a half that that kind of roll
around and for some companies it might
make less of a difference you're valuing
craft TS or Coca-Cola not much might
have happened but you're valuing Nvidia
think of how much has happened in the
last week forget about the last year and
a half
you don't want to use the last 10K if
it's
dated you don't want to use the last
quadrant multiply by four which really
gives you a choice between C and D okay
I stick with C why because D you might
get an analyst estimate for the fourth
quarter but not for all of the items
remember you need revenues you need the
whole income
statement we're going to talk about
getting trailing 12- Monon data and how
many Financial filings do you need to
get a trailing 12mth data yeah s seems
like a stupid question but there's a
trick embedded in there sounds like you
should have four right you really don't
need four quarters of data to get a
trailing 12 month data all you need is
110k and the most recent 10q the reason
is very simple when you get the third
quarter 10q for 2024 it'll report the
numbers for the first three quarters of
2024 and the first three quarters of
2023 do you see how this the math now
works out to get a trailing 12 month you
take the last 10K add the first three
quarters the last 10K will be 2023
numbers add the first three quarters of
2024 it's not advanced math basically
you're taking 110k and 110 Q so we'll
talk about that process but you want the
most updated information you can some of
you are working with private businesses
where the updating might be even less
frequent Lisa how often does your
business update Financial do they do
full she's doing a privately owned
business annually so basically you're
stuck with one year you know Beggars
can't be choosers right you take what
you can get and you hope and pray that
sometime during the next couple of
months the 2024 numbers fully roll up
some of you are working in Emerging
Markets where you might not get full
quarterly statements you might get
partial quarterly statements much of
Europe until very recently you didn't
get full quarterly reports you got
revenues operating income three other
items and even in the US where you have
full quarterly statements not everything
gets updated for instance one of the
things we're going to talk about is
options to management and how that
affects your value that gets updated
only in the annual reports it won't show
up in the 10 go we're saying what do I
do take what you can get okay so your
objective is to take together all this
information some will be updated as of
May 5th some as of the last quarter some
of the last year and say this is the
most updated data I can get for each of
these items and I'm going to Value the
company as of right now and
probably not fully today but somewhere
along this session and then and tomorrow
session we're going to talk about
Capital expenditures what are capital
expenditures what you in what you invest
and I remember my f my first accounting
class giving you this definition it's
what you invest to create benefits over
many years so if you're a Manufacturing
Company what would qualify as a capital
expenditure the factory you built but I
want to list out a few items and you
tell me whether they meet this overall
definition of capex which is you get
benefits over many years building a
manufacturing plant obviously right how
about R&D
expense does it know who does R&D
expense to get a benefit this year if
you're lucky maybe next year if you're a
pharmaceutical company you might have
this is super gapex if you think about
it right advertising by a consumer
product
company when a consumer product company
adver IES they have two objectives right
one is to get you to buy stuff today so
Coca-Cola ad they want you to run out to
the grocery store buy Coca-Cola what's
the other part of
advertising building brand NE I mean go
back and look at the Super Bowl ads none
of them were designed to actually get
you to do stuff now they were trying to
create brand names that they hope to use
next year two years Out 3 years out 5
years out to make
money recruiting and training expenses
for a consulting
firm that's your biggest asset right
people the people who walk in you see
where I'm going if you look at
accounting statements and you look at
capex on a statement of cash flows you
know which one of these items will show
up on a statement of cash flows only the
manufacturing plant accounting as we
know it was designed for the oldtime
manufacturing company and it's getting
frayed at the edges because it just
can't handle the businesses that
dominate the 21st C
we'll fix it because as I said we're not
accountants at least I'm not an
accountant if you want to be God help
you but you can be an accountant but we
can fix accounting statements to do the
right thing and we need to because this
is going to be a fundamental question
we'll have to ask in
valuation and finally definitely not
today but tomorrow we're going to talk
about tax
rats why because we live in a world
where we get to spend after tax income
you might wish you weren't you might
wish you were in Bermuda and maybe
you'll get a job there with the tax rate
is zero but that's not the world most of
us will live in and if you operate a
business you got to pay taxes and one of
the things we're going to we're going to
have to talk about is what the tax rate
we should be using in valuation is
because remember we're forecasting
future taxes paid and we'll run into two
choices one is to use what's an what's
called an effective tax rate an
effective tax rate is very simply an
average tax rate based on taxes paid
this year and your taxable income so if
you go to the income statement there'll
be a taxable income line item 800
million and then there'll be taxes paid
of 200 million 200 divid by 800 is an
effective tax rate but there's another
tax rate that'll be floating around the
discussions called a marginal tax
rate the marginal tax rate is the tax
rate you pay on the next dollar of
income you know where you'd find this
not in your company filings but in the
tax code let's see how familiar you are
with the Us corporate tax code does
anybody know what the federal corporate
tax rate in the US is right
now 21% you know what it used to be
until
2017 35% we're approaching a cliff you
know why we approach a cliff because U
the US has the strangest way of writing
taxes which is they can't change taxes
forever because the way you have to do a
budget reconciliation in the Senate to
get it through they got to put a
timeline where the tax law entirely
expires the 2017 tax law expires at the
end of 2025 which if nothing is done
means the corporate tax rate is 21% now
will go back to
35% that's just the federal tax rate 21%
so if you operate in the US remember you
get taxed on where you get your revenues
not on where your inome
Incorporated so if you have US income
you have to pay 21% are you done though
is that all that you have to pay in
taxes what else do you have to do state
state local they're all lined up one
behind the other saying I want my slice
I want my slice so by the time you add
those slices together your tax rate if
you're in California New York could be
25% 26% if you're in Florida it could be
a little lower but basically it's going
to be about 25% that's a marginal tax
rate could that change change this year
yeah like one of the things they're
talking about is lowering the marginal
tax rate for some us companies I think
primarily companies that have their
factories in the US to 15% could that
happen before the semester ends given
how slowly Congress acts probably not
but this too can become a variable right
because when you're projecting the tax
rate for your company you're not
projecting what it is today but what
will be in the future so as you go
through your valuation keep an eye on
how the tax code discussion is
evolving effective tax rate marginal tax
rate tax
Cod the us there is a tax code it
thousands of pages long but the effect
the tax rate itself you know there the
accounting firms PWC maintains the US is
not an issue it's easy to find it you
can go to Google Search what's a tax
rate in the US it'll give it to you it's
getting the tax rates for the remaining
160 or 180 countries in the world PWC
maintains a database it's free you can
access it where they give you what the
part of the reason you can't do it
yourself is some of this tax code is in
a different language and unless you can
speak Greek or Turkish you're going to
get stying so it's nice to have those
places to go but it is easy in fact I
steal the PWC so I actually admitt it to
stealing I steal their data I put it on
my web page as marginal tax rates by
country so if you if you want you can go
check out but basically that reflects
the tax rates as of right now but those
could be different a year from now two
years from now so effective tax which do
you think is higher for most companies
the effective tax rate or the marginal
tax
rate and in fact the average effective
tax rate for US companies is about 18%
what do I say the marginal tax rate
was 25% I wanted to think about why
effective tax rates might be lower than
marginal tax rates because answering
that question will let you decide how
best to pick which tax rate to use so
I'm going to leave that as a dormant and
not answer this question but we will
come back and talk about this when we
talk about which tax rates
use so let's go back to where I left you
in the lecture notes which is a long
time ago so you've probably forgotten
completely where we
were we were at the end of the cost
Capital calculate no we were talking
about the cost of debt do you remember
that
discussion I know you don't so act like
you
do how do you get a cost to debt
somebody help me out what do we start
with and
then defa spread okay so before we do
that so you need a default spread which
you can either go out and get if you
have a company that has a rating right
because or you got to estimate it we
talked about how to do it if you have a
rating if you can tell me what your
rating is as a company Triple B doubleb
There is a market number out there I can
say this is what a default spread is but
80% of companies around the world don't
have a rating and private businesses
definitely don't have a rating so don't
even go looking for a Moody's rating you
got to estimate a default spread does
anybody remember the process by which
you estimate a default spread what do we
do to get a default spread for companies
without a
rating did we look at what no that's a
separate issue because that's got
nothing to the
company we looked at how much income
they generated relative to their
interest expense and interest coverage
ratio then I had that lookup table which
sounds like it's magic but basically by
looking at rated companies said if I
were a moody rating you given your
interest coverage ratio of 3.56 or
5.2 this is what your rating will be and
that gave me a default spread my end
game is still getting a default sprad so
with the embri the the rating I gave
them was a minus given their interest
coverage
ratio I could take the default sprad for
an A minus and because I was doing
everything in US Dollars added to the T
bond rate and come up with the cost of
debt but there's one catch it's a
Brazilian company you're saying so what
for a long time the ratings agencies
used to actually have what's called a
rating
ceiling anybody know what a rating
ceiling for a company is
sophiax if you take a company in a
country no company in that country could
have a rating higher than the country so
if you're a Russian company God help you
now right because you don't have a
rating I'm not even going to try to rate
you so Russian companies none of them
are now rated because Russia is not
rated if you're a Venezuelan company you
could be the safest Venezuelan company
in the face of the Earth and your rating
could not exceed the CAA or whatever the
junk bond status is it was a very unfair
ceiling because you could be a really
Safe Company getting all your revenues
outside the country and I was still
giving you that penalty so they've
removed rating tencies have actually
removed the rating sailing but where
you're incorporated as a company still
matters so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the default spread I get
for an A minus rating which is 1% and
I'm going to add on a portion of the
country default spread remember the
country default spread we estimated why
just a portion because embria gets 97%
of its revenues outside Brazil so I
think they can make their interest
payments perhaps a little easier than
the Brazilian government can to be quite
honest but if you're at all confused
about the two3 just take the two3 out
add the entire country default spread so
you're adding two default spreads to the
risk free rate one is for the company
one is for the country it's incredibly
unfair because you see what I've done
right if you're a Turkish company I've
essentially saddled you even if you
borrow money in Euros with this really
high cost of
debt and while it's unfair it is what
the world is so if you operate in some
countries you are encumbered by the risk
of that country so ultimately the end
game is you come up with a cost of debt
in this case it was in
us now this table that I showed you with
the interest coverage ratios and the
ratings I call those synthetic ratings
was developed almost entirely with us
companies when I started 30 years ago it
wasn't because I was being us Centric at
that that time most rated companies were
in the US even in Europe big companies
borrowed money from Banks there were
very few companies that used bonds today
when I do that that table I have more
non- us companies but it's mostly
developed Market companies
still and the countries where I often
have to use the stable are countries you
know Emerging Market countries where you
don't really have very many rated
companies I still use that table because
often I have no other choice it's not
like I can develop a table for Indonesia
and India because there aren't enough
companies to do
it but there's one qualifier I would add
you can use this table to come up with
ratings and default spreads as long as
your risk-free rate is not that
different from mine you remember what
the Indian rupe risk free rate was at
the start of
2025 it's about five 5 and a half% I can
live with the default spread you get but
if I took the Turkish Le
risk free rate remember it was
21% taking these default spreads and
putting it on top of 21% risk free rate
might understate the cost of debt
because if you can make 21% risk free
why would you lend to somebody at 23% or
24% You' probably charge them 27 so this
table travels well as long as you're
talking about single digit risk free
rates you get into into double digit
you're saying what do I do I'll give you
a way around those particular currencies
hopefully most of you will not be
dealing with them but that's the only
caveat I would add Now the default
spreads
themselves a market at you know I don't
know how many of you discovered the
Bloomberg I sent you that really long
document on what you can pull up for
your company but do find the Bloomberg
no because remember once you leave here
if you're not working at a place that
has Bloomberg terminals you know how
much one of those terminals cost to get
like a $100,000 there's a reason Michael
Bloomberg is worth 5 billion it's like a
cash cow that keeps on giving but use it
because it's actually a great trading
tool it's not a great investing tool
it's not going to tell you what to buy
or sell great trading
tool so you can look up the default
spreads and you know on Bloomberg what
the spreads look like right now so if
you look at default spreads and I've
looked at it for 1 two three four seven
seven ratings here and this is in
2022 right when inflation started to
appear and make itself an issue so
markets were melting down people were
getting scared when people get scared
what do they do they push up the price
of risk you saw this with the equity
risk premium popping up in both 2008 and
2020 2022 as well and default spreads
also went up this is the price of risk
in the bond market and it is in motion
what that effectively means though is
when you want to come up with the cost
of debt for your company today you want
an updated default spread as right now
you don't want to use a default spread
from 2 years ago 5 years ago I updated
the default spreads on my web page at
the start of
2025 but by the time you get April could
that be different I hope not but it
could right you could have something
that causes it to move I'll give you a
link where you can go the get the
updated spread so if you want to know so
keep it your rating is not going to
change but your default spread could
change one final point about uh the cost
of debt and then we're going to move on
so we've talked about a market driven
cost of debt right risk free rate plus
default spread there are companies out
there that can access debt at subsidized
rates who gives them the subsidized debt
governments might why would go
governments offer subsidized debt to a
company why do they give I mean a lot of
green energy companies got subsidized
debt right what was the end game
there that you wanted
to you wanted to fight climate change
and you wanted to help the companies
that you thought would fight climate
change so there are companies out there
with subsidized de so I want to focus on
EMB embra used to be a Brazilian
government-owned company it is now a
publicly traded company but it remains a
crown jewel for the Brazilian government
something they can point to and say we
have a world-class aircraft
manufacturing
company let's assume that the Brazilian
government is willing to lend money to
EMB at a $ 6% interest rate remember
their actual cost of debt is 9.29% right
at a 6% cost of debt so they're able to
borrow it 6% your value and BR does the
fact that they can borrow it 6% is this
a good thing or a bad thing for your
valuation is it going to make your value
higher or
lower it's going to make it valuation
will be higher because you're getting a
subsidy right you're able to borrow
money so my question is where in this
valuation will you bring in that benefit
one is you can when you compute the cost
of capital you can use the subsidized
cost of debt which will lower your cost
of capital lower your discount rate and
increase
value but if you do that you got to be
careful why because if you make that
your cost of capital
forever what are you assuming about the
subsidized debt that'll go on
forever so I I try not to do because I
forget that I got this cheap debt and I
leave it in my terminal value reflects
it and before I know it I'm assuming the
government will keep lending to me at 6%
so here's the other option leave the
cost of debt at the 9.29% we came up
with with the default spreads you're
going to get two higher cost of capital
right but it is a reflection of what you
would face eventually value a company
with that cost of capital and then bring
in the benefit you got from the subsidy
let's focus just on the subsidy right
you should have been borrowing money so
let's say you have 100 million in debt
you should have paid
9.29% but instead you paid 6% how much
do you save in interest expenses each
year 3,290 right or 3 so it's the 3.29%
times the amount you borrow take the
present value of those savings let's say
for the next 10 years you keep it so
basically you're saying I'm not going to
get this subsidy forever I'm going to
get for the next 10 years take the
present value of that interest savings
and just add it on one of the nice think
about doing discounted cash flow
valuations valuations additive you can
bring that in so if you're getting
subsidies from the government for
whatever better to keep it out of your
valuation than bring it in the last step
you're not ignoring it but you're
treating it as something that's separate
and that could go away and one final
point when governments give subsidies do
they usually want something in return
I'm a cynic here there's usually another
shoe waiting to drop drop right and one
of the things I ask companies to do is
when they say the government can give me
the subsidy my question is what do you
have to do in return maybe you have to
sell your products at a lower price
maybe you have to go into markets you
otherwise wouldn't have gone into and
that is a net cost and then you got to
ask yourself is the benefit of getting
the subsidy greater than the cost
because you might end up deciding that
it's better not to get the subsidy and
go after the markets but if you push
this all into your cost of capital it
becomes very difficult to answer that
question so we got a cost of equity
coming from the risk free rate the bait
and the equity risk Prem we've got a
cost of
debt coming from a risk free rate and a
default spread so you got those two
numbers we need weights now right for
equity and
debt the rule in every Corporate Finance
textbook every valuation book is the
weights have to be market value weights
but nobody tells you why it's almost
like it's religion take it it's Market
valuates any of you doing a
CFA you're doing a CFA which which level
are you doing preparing for two this is
the most incredibly torturous exerise
known to man how many thousands of pages
have they made you read so far too many
to even remember like 6,000 pages and
then on a test they ask you what was on
page
4755 and if you don't know they fail you
they have to fail about 70% of the
people taking the test that's how they
keep the CFA
valuable I don't have a CFA but I've
given the CFA keynote for like 30 plus
years until I call them factless for
pushing an ESG certificate but no that's
a different
question I've begged them to allow me to
write the exam one year you ready this
is going to be the unofficial CFA
certificate if you can answer this
question I'll give you a CFA certificate
you to put in Brackets demotor and next
to it's not an official certification so
here's the question when you value
companies you're supposed to use market
value weights for equity and debt why
and I'll give you the four possible
answers is because is it because the
market is usually right what's wrong
with that if I use that justification
what's the problem I'm going to create
for
myself no no no don't go there because
then you're playing into my right so I
if I say the market is usually right I
come up with the cost of
capital I'll value the company and at
the end of the valuation what am I going
to tell you the stock is undervalued
overvalued and you have me over a barrel
right you you told me the markets are
usually right so how come you're the
special one so don't even try that it's
not because markets are usually right is
it because markets value are easy to get
as opposed to what book values just as
easy to get right is it because book
values of debt and Equity are
meaningless I know I say mean things
about accountants but meaningless may be
too strong word they may be dated
they're not meaningless so it's none of
the
above so what do you think the right so
if somebody says tell me why we use
market value weights to come up with
cost to Capital when we're doing
intrinsic
valuation because after all in intrinsic
valuation we claim the market is
wrong why are we using Market valuates
because if you want to acquire
additional Capital funds in Project
you will not be borrowing you know at
book values or B you will be borrowing
from the market okay so that's for the
cost of debt it's got to be an update
it's got to be a market value and you
raise Equity it has to be market value
as well so that's actually a good first
level answer when for corporate finance
cost of capital because there it's a c
but we're valuing the entire company
here right we're not taking the next
project so this is to be an even
stronger argument and I'll give you the
answer and I'll give you all cfas as a b
bonus you came in on a Tuesday I think
you deserve a CFA when you leave this
room here's the reason we use market
value weights every discounted cash flow
valuation is an acquisition valuation in
Disguise you're acting like you're
buying the entire company today so tell
me what'll have to happen for you to go
buy the entire company you'll have to go
buy all of the debt at the market value
and you'll have to buy all of the equity
not at your intrinsic value or Book
value at the market value it's a
transactional cost of capital
that's why we can live with the fact
that the market values we use to come up
with the cost of capital will be
different from the intrinsic values we
arrive at for the same company at the
end of the process because the intrinsic
value is what we think a company is
worth but you can't go offering that to
investors because there's a market price
the market value of equity and debt is
used not because the market is right but
because that's a transactional
cost now of course if the argument that
market value wage should be used for the
cost of capital Lisa is going to be in
trouble she's going to need a cost of
capital for a company for a privately
owned business and I'm going to ask you
what the market value of equity for your
business what's your answer going to
be there's no market value of equity
it's a privately H business we're going
to come back and talk about how to come
up with weights for private businesses
or divisions where there is no market
value
equity and that but the one thing you
can't use is book values so don't even
look at the balance sheet that's not the
place to go but ultimately the weights
have to be market value
weights so it took us a long time to get
to this page I've talked about Embraer
off and on for about 50 pages let me
bring it all together in one page and
try to compute a cost of capital for EMB
remember I decided to do everything in
US Dollars that was a choice I made up
front because there was no Government
Bond in r at that time my risk free rate
is therefore the US bond rate that's a
4.2 9% let's go through the cost of
equity there's the 4.29% risk rate the
1.07 is the bottom up beta for embro
based on global aerospace companies we
threw away the regression
beta the equity risk premium for a
mature Market in 2004 was 4% you're
saying what about the fact that this is
a Brazilian company the Lambda that I
estimated for EMB based on that
regression of embri returns against the
Brazilian dollar Bond was .27 it's not
as risky as thep iCal Brazilian company
and multiply the Lambda by the equity
risk bre if you're using the the more
common approach which is to take a
weighted average basically all that will
happen is you won't have the third term
but your Equity risk premium then be a
weighted average of a US risk premium
and a Brazilian Equity risk premium cost
of equity in dollar terms of 10.7%
market value of equity was 11.04 billion
R based on the market price times number
of shares outstanding
it's a market cap of the company for the
debt the cost of debt is risk-free rate
plus the country default spread for
Brazil That's a 4% plus the company
default spread why Country default
spread because it's a Brazilian company
and I'm doing my cost of debt in dollar
terms my cost of debt is
9.29% and the market value of debt is
2,83
million market value of equity for a
public company is easy to get right go
look up the share price market cap where
do you get market value of debt for a
publicly traded
company if bonds if all of its debt is
in the form of traded bonds you can take
the bond price you're almost never going
to see that happen you take a company
like apple one of the largest market cap
companies in the world it has about 100
billion in debt 80% of it is in the form
of bonds most of which are not traded
the remaining 20 billion is in Bank 10
so even companies that are high-profile
companies a big chunk of the debt is not
going to be trade so getting market
value of debt is a pain in the neck so
anybody worked in Investment Bank in the
summer when it came to cost of capital
you probably use the market value of
equity unless you worked at a really bad
Investment
Bank but when it came to debt you know
what most investment Banks use because
they can't get in market value of
debt they use the book value of debt and
they do some hand waving they say Market
debt and book Debt are not going to be
that different so it's okay to use no
and I get it I for many companies it
probably not not a big deal but there's
a way in which you can convert book Debt
to Market debt and I'm going to try to
take you through that it's not rocket
science if you don't want to do it
that's fine but if you ever want to
convert book Debt to Market debt try
this
out do you know how to value a price a
regular coupon Bond what do we do
today right you take the coupon payments
in the face value and you discount them
back at a market interest rate today
what you get as a present value is the
price of the bond today I'm going to
take that and I'm going to use that to
Value all of the debt that andrier has
and here's how I'm going to do it EMB
had a book value of debt of 1.953125
of your bond it had interest payments of
222 million each year think of that as a
coupon every year and its maturity for
the debt was 4 years so you're going to
get 122 million in coupons for the next
four years and you're going to get 1,953
million the end of the fourth year
remember the pre-tax cost of debt we
estimated today was
9.29% if I discount the coupons back and
the pH value at
9.29% what I get as a present value for
the debt is 283
million essentially it's a market value
of debt because I've taken the coupon
payments of the face value discounted
them all back today okay so when you
look at book Debt and you want to
convert to Market debt all you're doing
is treating it like you would a
traditional bond with the interest
payment standing in for the coupon and
the book value standing in for the face
value again for most companies you can
get away using book de you know where
this will make a big difference
what kinds of companies is the market
debt going to be most different from the
book
Debt first in 2022 what happened to
interest
rates they shot up right so if your book
Debt came in 2020 or 2021 if you took
that debt in
2023 it' be about 30% lower than it was
in 2021 so that's what corporate bonds
did even if your rating did not change
the second scenario is if you are a
doublea rated company and your rating a
slit to to Triple C you're junk ponds
right what you're effectively going to
get is a market debt that's much lower
than the book Debt but that's the
reality you got to work with that's the
debt you should be
including one final example and then
we'll kind of move on remember I said
when you get to really high interest
rates adding default spreads in equity
and the country risk gets kind of tricky
because many of those numbers are in
Dollar in dollar terms all of that
entire Equity risk premium page that you
saw was a dollar Equity risk premium and
most of the time if you add that on to
Rupee risk free
rate or a uan risk free rate I'm going
to say it's going to be okay you 3% 4%
risk free rates now what difference does
it make but if you get to a 12 14 15%
risk free rate it can make a
difference so let's take the Brazilian
RI risk free rate was 12% I could stay
with Brazilian RIS and do everything
Brazilian R but then I'm taking dollar
risk premiums and adding them on to a
risk-free rate in R so there's my cost
of cost of equity and cost of debt if I
take just the US the numbers that I have
as default spreads and risk PRS add them
on to risk R but I have a feeling though
those numbers are going to be too low
because I've taken a high risk free rate
and added a spread that I got from a
much lower risk free rate in bu so
here's the alternative if you have
really high risk fre rates you're
working in Turkish
L you're working in a currency with 10
15 20% risk free rates do everything in
US Dollars even though you're going to
do your valuation in that
currency your cost of capital let's say
is 99.97% in dollars right then all you
need to do to convert to a ninal r risk
free rate is estimate the expected
inflation in RIS and the expected
inflation in dollars remember with this
adjustment we did with the risk fre rate
if the inflation rate in in reiz is 8%
inflation rate in dollars is 2% the
9.97% dollar cost of capital will become
a 16.44% re cost of capital basically it
scales up the risk premium because you
have such a high risk fre rate so with
very high risk free rates it's probably
best to work in a different currency
till the last moment and then do this
adjustment as the last
step we're almost the end of the cost of
capital got Equity you got debt take the
weights but I'm assuming that everybody
everything fall into those two buckets I
want to talk a little bit about some of
your companies where you're going to see
Securities that I'm going to call
hybrids what are hybrids they're part
debt part
Equity let me give you the two most
common examples of hybrids you have a
convertible
Bond how does a convertible Bond work do
you
know no you don't wait till it matures
it'll be too late if it wait till it
matures becomes a regular Bond so you
buy a convertible Bond if you hold it to
maturity you get the coupons and the
face value which is like a regular Bond
but during the period that you hold it
you get an option to convert into into
common stock why would you exercise that
option yeah you have convertible Bond
and Invidia you're cashing out and
moving on saying I don't want to hold
this as a bond I'm going to convert to
shares and make my spoils so there's an
option to convert into equity which is
really Equity plus is straight Bond a
convertible bond is part debt part
Equity no it's a what's the essence of
an
option it's it's a strike price
otherwise it's not an option right it's
a Futures Contra so the advantage of a
convertible Bond you want an Invidia
convertible Bond would be that you can
convert at $80 the stock is at 125 you
are going to convert to the conversion
option so it's debt plus Equity that's
easier hybrid to deal with there's a
second group of hybrids called preferred
stock NOW preferred stock in the US is
very different from preferred stock in
Latin America preferred stock in Latin
America is this common stock without
voting rights preferred stock in the US
is more like a bond than stock how does
it work when you buy a preferred stock
you get a fixed dividend like a coupon
3% 5% 7% that dividend is not quite
guaranteed by the don't pay it's
accumula and paid in future periods you
thinking this is great why would I ever
buy common stock because remember you're
buying more Bond than stock you're not
going to get the upside that you'd get
with convertible debt or with
traditional stock if you own preferred
stock in Nvidia you're still collecting
the 7% dividend or the 5% dividend but
you're getting none of the
upside so one reaction to preferred
stock is if it's like that let's put it
in with the rest of debt but it has one
small problem when you you borrow money
what was the tax advantage you were
getting interest expenses are tax
deductible with preferred stock you
don't get that tax reduction so one
reason I can't just add it to debt and
then I multiply by one minus the tax
rate it's not going to work because I
don't get the tax bettered I'll be quite
honest preferred stock is a pain in the
neck I wish it did not exist it's a
suboptimal security that should never
have been created but it's out there you
know who are the biggest users of
preferred stock what what sector
it's Banks you know why Banks use it
because the regulatory authorities
actually treat it like regular Equity so
it allows them to borrow
money without issuing additional without
you know without the consequences of
borrowing money it basically shows up as
Equity so it gives them the it's a
terrible way to raise Capital but it
allows you to play this regulatory game
so if you have preferred stock my
advices open up a third component your
Capital you'll have debt you'll have
equity and you'll have preferred stock
the weight still have to add up to
100% but effectively it's a third way of
raising Capital
Sophia ins for
example how do we
deal okay does everybody get sopia's
sopia's question was in many Muslim
countries companies and countries cannot
issue
bonds why because it goes against
religion according to Islam you cannot
charge interest because it's viewed as
you know exploiting the other person so
what do they have to do they have to
dress up their debt as something else
right they can't call it bonds but
effectively it is borrowing money so
they will dress it up you just have to
look past what they call it treat it as
debt and move on there will be no tax
benefit which means there's really no
good reason for you to be borrowing
money in the first place but if you
insist on doing it I'm going to Tre as
debt no matter what you call it so don't
let what somebody calls something let
you know decide whether it's debt or
Equity because if there is a contractual
claim against you aren care what it's
called it's dead okay we'll talk about
this in the context of leases later so
with preferred stock just treat it as a
third source of capital make sure the
weights add up to 100% usually the cost
of preferred stock will fall somewhere
between your cost of equity and your
cost of debt will be lower than your
cost of equity but higher than your cost
of
debt this just to illustrate what you
could do if you have a convertible bond
to break into debt and Equity let's say
you have a convertible Bond okay usually
when you have a convertible Bond the
coupon rate will be low on the bond
that's one reason companies like to
issue it why is it low because you're
effectively giving Equity to the person
buying the bond so let's say you have a
convertible bond with a $125 million
face value and a 4% coupon rate let's
also assume that you got 10 years of
left on your on your bond if I just
value this as a bond which would be 4%
of 125 million be my coupon 125 million
at the end of 10 years would be my face
value what I get as a present value is
about 91 million so if I bought this
just as a bond I forgot all about the
conversion option I'd pay 91 million for
this Bond the bond is actually trading
at 140 million so what's the extra 48.5
million for it's for the conversion
option that I got in the Box
so if I have 140 million in convertible
debt 91 million will go into debt the
remaining 49 million I'll put into
Equity my hybrid security is now gone
away it's gone into debt and Equity so
if you have a hybrid that you can break
down to debt and Equity break it down
it's better to have only two components
in your cost of capital and not keep
adding more and for God's sakes don't
take the debt and make it into
short-term debt you know medium-term
debt long-term debt there only one debt
give it one cost cuz otherwise you
create a nightmare for
yourself that's about it so we've got
cost of equity coming from a risk-free
rate in a bottom up beta cost of debt
based on your default spread weights
based on market value your weighted
average of your cost of equity and your
after tax cost of debt and here remember
the two tax rates I talked about the tax
rate you should always use for your cost
of debt is your marginal tax
rate again something often asserted in
books why is that why do we use the
marginal tax rate when we compute the
tax benefits from
that what put it we at no 6 weeks away
from tax day right or8 weeks away let's
suppose you decide to do your taxes and
let's hypothesize that you you made a
lot of money last year doing what I
don't know I want you know something
illegal you know something legal it was
illegal you probably don't want to
report to the IRS so let's make it
legal you made a million dollars last
year if that's insulting add an extra
zero and you are $100,000 in interest
expenses help me out how does that work
in terms of taxes you have a million
dollar in income you have $100,000 in
interest expenses what are you allowed
to do subtract the 100,000 and Report
taxable income of $900,000
think of why you saved on taxes not in
the first 100,000 not in the middle
100,000 but in the last 100,000
it's a marginal tax rate that you get
tax benefits on how many of you plann to
live and work in New York City after you
graduate God help you in terms of
marginal tax rates you want to know what
your marginal tax rate in New York City
will be let's start with the federal tax
rate right I'm going to give you a high
enough income that you hit the highest
marginal tax rate the federal level
otherwise it be 37.6% that's your
starting point what's your next stop you
file your federal taxes 3 7.6% then you
open up your New York state taxes you
know the marginal tax rate is at that
level of income in New York state it's
about 10 and a
half% oh don't relax yet I'm not done
with you so I had the 37.6 10 and a half
you might get a few benefits on the side
but even the the old savings you got
from paying federal taxes are gone so
you're paying close to 48% you know I
asked you not to relax you're in New
York City is there a New York City tax
there's about a 3.6% tax only of time
before Chelsea decides it wants its own
tax too and then your neighbor will have
in the in New York your marginal tax
rate by the time everything is said and
done will be about
50% you know the good newses is when you
borrow money now you will get a much
higher tax benefit than somebody lives
in
Idaho so when you borrow money to buy
that apartment building 50% marginal tax
rate will kick in the marginal tax rate
is what you pay on that last dollar of
income and that's why when we do cost of
debt we always use
that so think about it we got a lot of
moving pieces none of the moving pieces
is by itself difficult but they're messy
there are so many moving piece it's easy
to get distracted and miss one of them
so keep it structured keep it organized
do it one step at a time and you can
come up with the cost of capital for
your
account so now let's talk about cash
flows
free cash flow is probably the most
dangerous word in business I see it used
all the time analy use the free cash
flow is that's incomplete free cash flow
by itself doesn't tell me much you got
to tell me whether it's to the firm or
it's to equity and what's the
difference
sopia after if to equities after debt
payments the firm is before debt payment
so the starting point reflects it when I
do free cash Ro Equity my starting point
is net income when I do free cash to the
firm my starting point is earnings
before interest in taxes or operating
income you see why I can't start with
net income and I'm doing free cash for
the firm net income is after interest
expenses I've got to climb the income
statement so I start with different
measures of earnings from the income I
subtract out what I have to reinvest as
a business are businesses required to
reinvest is there a law that says now
why do we reinvest that what's what's
the payoff
what happens if I don't reinvest if I
say look I'm going to take all the money
out I could do that as a business what
do I give
up if I want to talk about growth in the
same breath I've got to tell you what I
reinvest right one goes with the other
and that reinvestment can be in
long-term assets land building equipment
it could include things like R&D we'll
talk about that or it can be in
reinvestment in short-term assets
working capital inventory receivables so
I subtract out reinvestment from from
both in the case of operating income
because I start with a pre-tax number I
also have to net taxes out and there
we're going to come up with the question
what tax rate to use why don't I have to
net taxes out from net
income think about an income statement
where does Net Income come in at the
very end it's after taxes so net income
is already after tax the operating
income is not so in the case of free
cash FL Equity I have to keep going not
only do I have to subtract our
reinvestment I also have to now capture
cash flows to and from debt cash flows
to debt will be interest payments
principal repayments cash flows from
debt will be new debt that I take on as
a company and in fact if I have you know
if I have other cash flows to debt
holders I've got to factor that in and
what I'm left with is free cash flow to
equity so the next time somebody has
free cash flow stops and to equity to
the firm and say What's the difference
you should be able to explain free cash
flow equities after debt payments and
after cash flows to debt free cash flow
to the firm you start with operating
income you net out taxes you subtract
out reinvestment you're done what about
debt payments debt payments are not
factored in when you do free cash flow
to the firm
so I'm going to go through a process
basically and I'm going to try to be as
orderly as I can I'm going to start by
looking at the current earnings of the
firm now before I get ambitious about
future earnings I want to look at
current income statement say what can I
learn about the firm and I can look at
net income or I can look at operating
income then I'm going to subtract out
what a company will have to reinvest
back I'm going to start with traditional
measures of capex and depreciation but
I'm also going to bring in R&D and other
things that I think should be treated as
reinvestment and if you're a company
like a retail company that as you grow
your inventory grows with you I'm going
to factor the as well so I'm going to
start with earnings look at reinvestment
if you're free looking at free cash
Equity I'm also going to look at cash
flows to and from De so the sequence is
pretty straightforward if you
follow now if you look through the
lecture notes or you look through
practice problems or the quiz problems
you notice free cash equity and free
cash of firm problems and multiple ways
in which I seem to have got there
they're all equivalent so in this page
I've kind of listed out different ways
in which I can get to free cash for I
can start with after tax operate income
and subtract our dollar reinvestment
I get to free cash for the firm if I
take the dollar reinvestment and call it
reinvestment I'm talking about the same
thing so from this point on when you see
reinvestment talked about in this class
it includes everything capex working
capital
Acquisitions or I could take what you
reinvest back and state it as a
percentage of your after tax operate
income and call it a reinvestment rate
I'm changing nothing right 1,000 - 400
is 600 1,000 minus 1 minus point4 is
also 600 basically I'm stating it the
only reason I want you to get
comfortable with the different
definitions is not just to solve past
prts but there will be at some points in
the future when we talk about growth
where one or another of these different
measures is going to come into play so
you start with earnings and you kind of
step down to free cash for the FM so a
couple of years ago I did a post on
Microsoft that I'll take you through
basically you can see me start with
earnings and work down when you're doing
free cash flow to equity again are there
multiple ways I can get there each of
the ways starts with net income the
first way I look at total reinvestment
second I consolidate and then call it
reinvestment third I take all these
numbers including the debt payments and
I call it and as as a percentage of net
income I call it an equity reinvestment
rate it's like basically what percentage
of my net income am I putting back in
the business there's an advantage of
stating reinvestment as a perent of
earnings and that's what I've done the
these calculations so this was my
Microsoft calculation I'll send you the
blog post just to illustrate what
happens between the St time you start
with earnings you end up with cash flows
first one is free cash flow Equity I
start with net income this first red
column is actually my reinvestment for
Microsoft a lot of that was in R&D and
in Acquisitions the second is my debt
cash flows why is it so small because
Microsoft doesn't have very much debt
net those two out you get a free cash
flow equity which is about 60 % of its
net income if you do free cash FL to the
firm there's the starting point there's
my taxes remember that free cash flow to
the firm I'm starting with operating
income I have to net out taxes net out
reinvestment as my free cash for the
firm when you do this for your for your
for your company it might actually be
good to take those numbers that you have
in a spreadsheet put it in a picture so
you can see what you start with and what
you step down to because it'll help you
frame what your company is doing if this
number is very close to this number
number that means you're not reinvesting
much and then when you estimate growth
and tell a growth story for your company
you either have to change how much they
reinvest or you going to bring down how
quickly they can grow because you can't
have high growth without putting money
back into the
businesss that
happened so let's talk about earnings
because that's the starting point when I
look at the earnings for a company
remember this is going to become the
basis for what I'm going to forecast for
the future there are three things that I
always start off trying to clean up for
first we talked about updating numbers
you want the most updated numbers you
can get and I've already given you a
pathway to get there right don't use the
last 10K get trailing 12 month
numbers if you use Capital IQ it'll
always give you a trailing 12month
number I think yahooo Finance gives you
a trailing 12month number as well so
getting it is not difficult
second earnings in any given year can do
weird stuff especially with commodity
and cyclical companies
I remember in 2020 almost every Oil
Company in the world reported
losses I think outside of aramco every
other Oil Company lost money why because
during 2020 oil prices dropped to $30 a
barrel no oil company in the world can
make money at $30 a barrel does that
mean these companies are worth nothing
absolutely not because commodity prices
move in Cycles so when you have one
year's number and you're working through
a cycle do the sensible thing normalize
that number by looking at averages
across time we'll talk about how this
plays out over what period but basically
you're replacing a single Year's number
with an average across time and third
clean up clean up after accountants
because they've left quite a
mess there are two things I'm going to
talk about cleaning up first is a
financial expense that they've routinely
treated as an operating
expense that you got to clean up for
starting in 2019 they've started doing
the right thing and I'm talking about
leases leases have always been dead I'll
talk about the long and torturous
history it took accounting to get to
that conclusion but we'll talk about
what it is that makes lease's debt then
expand that discussion the second is
what I talked about with r& and
recruiting and training expenses those
have been treated as operating expenses
and those are really Capital expenses so
let's
start with this updating earnings number
it's it's the easiest step in the
process right so you have trailing
12-month numbers or you can use these
informal numbers I'll give you my
rationale for why I stick with trailing
12 month numbers for many of you those
trailing 12 month numbers right now are
through September it can by you know by
the time you get to March or April it
should become 2024 numbers and you
should have updated numbers but some of
you might actually and Sophia mentioned
this might get an earnings report
between March 31st and May 6th and if
you can update
hopefully it won't be May 4th or May 3rd
you know if you can update you want to
update those numbers so use 110k 110 q
and I'll you know I'll put up a webcast
on how the two can be combined but you
can get the most updated numbers you can
by using those trailing 12 month
numbers but let me talk a little bit
about the corrections I'm going to make
to accounting earnings because the
process I'm going to describe is a
process you can use to clean up any
accounting
State when I took my first accounting
class
my my accounting professor came in with
three cardboard boxes he labeled them
the first box was labed operating
expense the second was labeled Capital
expense and the third was labeled
financing expense in the operating
expense box he threw in things like
labor material things that were designed
to create a benefit just this year the
capital expense box he threw Factory
equipment things that lasted many years
and the financing expense B through an
interest expenses and he sets something
that I didn't know then was a lie but
now I realize was a complete lie he said
in accounting we're religious about the
way we categorize expenses because
everything has a
place let's take the operating expenses
where in the financial statements do you
see operating expenses
go did they show up in the balance sheet
no they just go directly into the income
statement right below revenues right so
you subtract our operating expenses
labor material cost of good sold what
happens to Capital
expenses what's their first stop they
show up in the balance sheet as an asset
and then in subsequent periods what are
you required to do depreciate or
amortise them they show up in the income
statement then and if you're financing
expenses you go back to the income
statement but now below the operating
income
line I remember thinking this is so neat
and
orderly but the chaos underlying what
they were doing was kind of not revealed
because the two things I'm going to
focus on are two things that have been
around for 40 years where it's obvious
that they're screwing up but getting
them to admit that they're screwing up
and doing the right thing has not always
worked the first is
leases what are leases leases are
contractual obligations you've entered
into and the minute you say contractual
obligations you don't have to even go
any further that's that anytime you have
a contractual commitment to make
payments you've effectively borrowed
money leases have always been de until
2019 accountants routinely categorized
almost 90% of lease expenses as
operating expenses what kinds of
businesses do you think have a lot of
lease
commitments I'm sorry what restaurants
retailers most of their debt is actually
least debt and until 2019 you looked at
a Walmart or a Target they look like
they didn't borrow much money which was
a complete lie because they borrowed
tens of billions of dollars in the form
of lease
commitments we talk about the accounting
rationale for why they did the stupid
thing that they did in 2019 but until
2019 you had to convert leases to Deb
because they didn't do it for you
already talked about capex being in
expenses for multiple periods the
biggest item that accountants routinely
miscategorized as R&D you're a
technology firm you know how you grow
you put a lot of money to R&D you're a
pharmaceutical company billions of
dollars in R&D
and even through today across much of
the world when you have R&D expenses
that're treated as operating expenses
it's mindboggling if you think about it
saying how would you do it I'll give you
some of the or maybe you can come up
with some of the accounting explanations
for why they treat R&D as an oper
expense but it's clearly a capital
expense so what I'd like to do is start
with leases and work through so here are
the businesses which are the highest
lease expenses of percent of sales so
you can see the types of business Air
transport what are we talking about all
those
aircraft that you're seeing Delta United
they don't own the aircraft they lease
them and for much of history that lease
has been treated as an operating expense
today it shows up as debt but induced to
trucking restaurant dining Wireless
Telecom so basically somehow it be a
surprise but most of them are what you'd
expect to be businesses with the lowest
and no surprises there not not much in
Le in these businesses what accountants
are doing was irrelevant but in the in
the businesses where leases are a big
item of expense clearly what accountants
are doing are skewing financial
statements so here's what I'd like to do
I would like to convert operating leases
to debt and I'm going to take you to the
process by which I used to do this
before 2019 because accountants wouldn't
do it for me now even before
2019 when accountants treated lease
expenses as operating expenses in the
footnotes us companies were required to
reveal what their contractual lease
commitments were for the next 5 years
and then a lump sum beyond your fire it
was a required
table so if I'm going to treat those
commitments as Dead all I have to do is
take the present value of those
commitments that table discounted back
at the pre-tax cost of debt we'll talk
about why pre-tax in a second and what I
get as a present value is the debt value
of
leases when you look at your company's
financial statements now the accountants
have this lease debt in the balance
sheet this is what they're doing in the
background to come up with those numbers
take the present value the commitments
so your debt value of
leases but when you put a debt value of
leases on a balance sheet as as a debt
the balance sheet has a prom it's
unbalanced right to balance it what do
you have to do you have to create what's
called a counter asset which is a least
asset so whatever you create as a least
Deb 2 billion you create a least asset
of 2 billion the Pain's not done once
you create asset what are you supposed
to do in subsequent periods you have to
depreciate this is like Give a Mouse a
Cookie at time have you read that book
you give the mouse a cookie he wants a
glass of milk you give him a glass of
milk he wants a read the book right
basically by the time he's done he's
taken over your
house this is not just converting one
thing you got to go through the process
so your lease asset has to be which
means your operating income is now
defunct right the operating income the
accountants reported is no longer right
because it was after the lease expense
you know to add back the lease expense
and subtract our depreciation Everything
Will Change Your earnings will be
different your debt will be different
your depreciation will be
different and prior to 2019 I used to do
this routinely for companies and it's
not a big deal it's a very structured
process so let's go back to
2003 I did this for The Gap at that time
time a growing retailer this these are
days are in the past opened up you know
dozens of new stores every year the Gap
didn't own a single one of its stores
every single Store The Gap had was
leased and in the US those leases were
typically 10 to 12 year
leases so the gaps ballot in the gaps
financials they revealed their
commitments their lease commitments for
the next 5 years and beyond your five
they gave me a lumsa of
1,976 is I split it out over two years
because I know they're not going to pay
it all in one year so I've got the lease
commitments the pre-tax cost of debt
that I came up for the for the for the
Gap was the risk free rate plus the
default sprad just like we did now let's
pause there why am I using a pre-tax
cost of debt to Discount these lease
commitments so
Fe it's not that they're not tax
deductible these are pre-tax commitments
if I did the 1 minus t on them and came
up with the after tax version I could
use the after tax C it's just a
consistency the lease commitments are in
pre-tax terms the discount rate has to
be in pre-tax terms what I get as a
present value 6.4 billion is the present
value of the lease commitments
yes owns places Andes them franchise
it's the other side of the because where
that's that's the people who collect the
leases so for McDonald's this will be an
asset not a debt
right for that in change
first are we valuing McDonald's or we
valuing a McDonald's
franchise we Val McDonald's it's an
asset so basically instead of being dead
we'll be doing the same thing but to
figure out what the asset is because
it's like a company that has bought
bonds rather than Soul bonds right so
essentially it's the same process but
now it'll become an asset which means
you got to create a counter liability
and create go through the same game but
you're looking at it from the other side
of the
transaction so what you get as debt here
4.4 billion I add to the the book
traditional Book value of debt the true
debt at the Gap is not the 1.97 billion
that you saw in the balance sheet it's
really 6.4 billion that's a big change
you get company like Walmart the Gap
Target this used to be a huge shift in
assessing how much debt they had for the
operating income I started with the
accounting operating income which is
about 1.01 billion I added back the
lease expensing I should never have
netted that out it's not operating
expense so that's what the plus 978 is
but now comes the other shoe waiting to
drop if my lease asset is 4.4 billion
and have a seven-year life and I'm going
to keep the life my life simple by using
straight line depreciation I'm going to
have depreciation of about 17th of 4.4
billion that's what the depreciation is
I'm subtracting out the depreciation
What You Get There is my adjusted
operating income is essentially the
operating income I'm going to use in
valuation once I do this page after this
this page everything I do with The Gap
has to reflect the least adjusted number
so when I talk about debt at the Gap
it'll be 6.4 billion when I do a cost of
capital for The Gap that'll be the debt
that I use in my cost of capital once
I'm I valued the firm and I subtract our
debt I'll be subtracting other 6.4
billion everything gets reframed based
on that so there's a shortcut you can
use which if you're in a hurry you can
get away with which is to take the
dollar debt that you get and multiply by
the pre-tax cost it's like an imputed
interest expense it's earnings before
interest taxes do that only if you're in
a hurry the right calculation is to add
back the lease expense and subtract
other depreciation so actually did this
at the Gap because they knew this change
was coming it's been coming for a long
time so 2003 they could see it coming
and they want to know what their numbers
would look like if you capitalize leases
I have to tell you up front that they
went through various stages of delirium
as I was going through it but kind of
came crashing down at the end so I
started with the good news I said if you
capitalize leases your operating income
will go from 1.0 billion to 1.36 billion
they said this is good higher operating
income then I said I have more good news
no right now when you do your cost of
capital your cost of capital is based on
traditional debt which is 1.97 billion
but if I bring in the leaste debt your
cost of capital is lower this is the
best of both worlds right you get higher
earnings and a lower cost of capital but
here are the other two shoes waiting to
drop in the old the accounting approach
where leases were not treated as dead
they had very little debt 1.97 billion
with Lees treated as debt I get 6.4
billion so you owe more than your debt
but here's the biggest change one of the
things you try to assess companies on is
how good their projects are right what
kind of return you make on your invested
Capital with the old assessment of
invested Capital they Ed the traditional
Book value it looked like the Gap was
making 12.9% as its return Capital which
is well above its cost of capital of
7.31 7. 31 %. but once I capitalize
leases and treat that as debt my return
on Capital becomes
99.3% at this stage they didn't know
whether they were coming or going
because they had good news and bad news
they said what does this all mean for
value is there a way that I can
crystallize this calculation and say
this is good for your company this is
going to hurt your company what what
should I look at given that everything
seems to be
changing but what drives the DCF what
defines the quality of project what you
make is Returns on projects versus the
cost of capital right what's the spread
they're earning right now about
5.59% after the correction they're
making about 3% as their
spread you're not as attractive a
company you're not taking projects that
are good and the real problem will be
companies that look good before you make
the adjustment but after you make the
adjustment they're actually earning less
than the cost of capital Starbucks used
to be a perfect example of this where
the return on Capital look great with
traditional accounting but once you
capitalize all of those Starbucks stores
around the country and you put them on
his debt they struggle to make their
cost of capital took them a while to
catch on 2017 Howard schs came back
again shut down like third of his stores
but it took them that shock therapy to
understand that when you take a lease
you're
effectively having a capital expenditure
I've got to treat it as part of invested
Capital remind me again why leases are
treated as de because they're
contractual commitments right anybody a
soccer fan
here what is Ronaldo's contract with
that Saudi team do you remember anybody
remember like a 150 million a year 120
million a year for four years mui came
very close to signing a billion dollar
contract almost 150 million for the next
7 years get about all of that show your
Tani 765 million is that a contractual
obligation for the
Mets if you're valuing the Mets right
now they're much more indebted than they
were a year ago why because it's borrow
a money it's called the SoDo Bond I'm
not saying it's good or bad but it's
there right when you value the met when
you look at a professional sports team
every big franchise player who sign on a
multi-year contract is like borrowing
money in fact I remember taking my all
four of my kids were still at home in
200 when the new Yankee stadium opened I
decided to make an offer to my kids I'll
take you all to opening day at the new
stadium because you can then tell your
kids and grandkids you were there on
opening day I had to withdraw the offer
from my daughter because she said will
there be dip and dots I said I'm not
taking you to Yankee Stadium and then
spending half the game looking for dip
and dots you can stay home so there's
nothing sexist about it dip and dots are
off the table so I take my three
sons it's a day game it's opening day of
course it's a day game and as the
Yankees run onto the field all I can
think of is debt and
Equity because there's a guy called Mark
T Shara who ran out to first base 30
million a year for the next six years
took the present value of that Robinson
Canó that time my cheap so basically you
went around the field added up the
present value of the contractual
commitments I got home and I did this
650 million just in the
infield try that when the Mets run out
this year the Dodgers that'll be a real
know watch them all fan out of the field
take every player's contract you'll have
a billion and a half in present value
contracts anytime you enter into
contractual commitment you've
effectively borrowed money one final
point he saying if this is always the
case why did it take accounting so long
to come around to that point in view you
know I I actually found a brochure from
1949 at the what is then called the NYU
business school there was an accounting
seminar which talked about why leases
should be treated as that 1949 when did
they say they finally fixed the problem
2019 it took them 70 years between
recognizing there was a problem and
doing something about what's the lesson
you learned from this don't wait for
accountants to do the right
thing you and I won't they
will they won't do it in your lifetime
of mine just do it yourself so rather
than complain about what accountants do
just fix what you don't like and move on
because our mission is very different
from theirs I'm not saying they're doing
the wrong thing but their mission is not
the same as mine so next class when we
start out we start off with
R&D Professor when you when you
normalize uh the future the future
earnings and you know that it's cyclical
can you predict in the cycle that you
know it's going to go down this year go
up next year or should you just
normalize to take the average of like a
5e span I would just take
predicting when there is a cycle the
cycle is not seven years 5 years it
could be 15 it could be three I tell you
the biggest problem what if the cycle is
broken n right right there's a historic
cycle but you can argue that the cycle
is going to be different because
electric cars require nickel significant
you can argue that what's coming is very
different from historical cyle
alternatively if you take if you take
something like iron oril which creates a
lot of carbon
you might say Okay given climate change
I think problem is not Cycles themselves
Cycles are easy if they repeat whether
cycle will come back right and when you
normalize you're assuming it comes back
okay that might get you into trouble
when whatever decision I make I need to
I need to write like almost the page of
just the story of like why how I got to
the valuation what I
did I wanted to ask two short questions
number one was um so using the